god what a good [ __ ] movie yeah it's
all Captain American Civil War for the
second time now we're gonna do some
spoiler talk you've already seen the
movie right now but you're getting it
now and that's a solid spoiler warning
for people who have not seen Captain
America's Civil War you do not want
spoilers you'd probably turn this off
now don't [ __ ] about it on my Twitter
don't worry this video will still be
here when you watch the movies just come
back after you watch it unless you don't
care about spoilers in which case
welcome let's talk about some spoilers
let's ruin a movie for it so you guys
already knew I love Captain America
Civil War the first time I saw here's a
little something for you it's better the
second time
even from the opening action sequence
this movie starts out The Avengers are
going after crossbones from Captain
America the Winter Soldier that's what I
feel the Russos do so well these Captain
America movies they make the action
gritty and real you're really on the
ground with them it reminded me of the
opening or at least the chase action
sequence in Casino Royale James Bond
with Daniel Craig long story short
crossbones has a dynamite vest is gonna
blow up Captain America hauls on boom
it's all contained and you see Scarlet
Witch she's there she's containing it
she just throws him up into orbit we're
not quite orbit he was going up and then
he blew up right in front of this
building and a bunch of innocent
civilians in there just ate [ __ ] and die
now the government's like alright guys
you need to be contained you need to be
controlled one thing I loved is when the
colonel Ross was you know secretary Ross
point is his mustache is breaking it
down to the Avengers like alright you
guys need to be reined in he's showing
them footage of [ __ ] that happens in the
trailer it was just trailer stock
footage it's like oh that's a shot from
The Avengers movie but it's not like a
camera shot that someone would have in
this one it's actually camera or cell
phone footage and I loved the part where
the Hulk is jumping it's from the first
Avengers and the Hulk jumps onto a
building all this debris follows on
whoever was recording that that person
probably died it goes along with the
theme of this movies we're all rooting
like oh yeah the Jews yeah you're
kicking ass but in the end like even
something like the Hulk going through
and jumping on building something that
got us all jacked up is like there are
casualties to that people die because
the Hulk was jumping on the building so
we were all rooting for people to die
kind of really brings it on course for
you we're like maybe they should be
controlled
maybe was jumping ahead on this I saw
one of the gripes about this movie
people were like Hawkeye didn't really
give a reason that he's joining the
fight he was just there for the sake of
him being there although it's not even
said in the movie but the way I see it
he's the one who told little max a
Marvel Scarlet Witch to go out there if
you go out there you are an Avenger he
gave her the pep talk
age of Ultron she went out there now
she's an Avenger and she's the one who
sent crossbows up there when he blew up
and so she feels responsible for
everyone dying in that building
Hawkeye probably feels responsible for
those people dying in that building
because he's the one who gave her the
pep talk that made her an Avenger the
way I say it anyway maybe I'm just
looking for a reason who know but really
when they're deliberating Tony Stark's
like we need to be put in check [ __ ]
like this is happening we are hurting
people Captain America's like
governments are run by people with
agendas and those agendas change what if
there's a place that they send us we
don't want to go what if there's a place
we should go that they don't send us I
feel like Donatello from Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles do like the secret of the
use I'm like he's right he's right
they're both right they both brought up
very good points I'm glad it wasn't so
black and white you know like Tony
Stark's the dick Captain America's it's
a good guy they ultimately ride that
line for as long as they can but in this
movie you really do see both sides and
really sad tragic news in this movie
that I don't really have a segue for I
don't know how to go from talking about
that to talk about this is agent Carter
dies in this movie it wasn't some big
thing she died in her sleep and at her
funeral her niece agent hottie is
talking about how she was talking with
agent Carter and she was like how did
you get ahead in a world that was
ultimately male-driven the agent Carter
didn't operate in the most progressive
form of the world
agent Carter told her compromise where
you can and where you will but where you
can't don't because at that point it's
your responsibility to tell the other
person no you move and you can tell it
really hit Steve Rogers he was like
that's me in this situation I I can't
budge on this I can't move and it was
such an important scene in this movie
because everyone has been in that
situation where you're like I can't
budge on this I can't I really truly
believe that I'm right I can't
compromise and if you haven't been in a
situation like that you will and when
you are you will love this movie even
more that's why I love about Bucky being
in the forefront of this movie remember
I told you in my spoiler free review
that ultimately this is a sequel to
Captain America Winter Soldier so the
Bucky Barnes Captain America thing
that's in the forefront you look at
Bucky Barnes in this movie Bucky was a
tool of Hydra that they use to exercise
their will and agenda Tony Stark's like
I'll bring him in bring him in bring him
in he needs to be brought in needs to be
brought to justice
all the while Tony Stark is advocating
the signing of this piece of paper that
would make
in the Avengers a tool of the government
to exercise their will in agenda so
ironically Tony Stark is saying that the
Avenger should be like what Bucky was
like it's a very ironic wheel of
circular reasoning that you're on when
you're watching this movie just gave the
movie a lot more flavor and you really
feel for Bucky in this movie Bucky is a
victim in all of this ultimately his
brain was scrambled and he was
brainwashed to do something that he
wouldn't have done otherwise Bucky
Barnes and Jessica Jones are the tragic
characters among the Marvel Cinematic
Universe both ultimately had their minds
controlled by someone else in Bucky's
case a collection of other people that
just use them as a smoking gun pretty
much they are a weapon for their will
and I love how Marvel's tackling the
factors like no that mess is a person up
so Jesse's so many other movies out
there's like a mind controlling they
snap out of it they're like yeah I'm
fine not in the Marvel world man now
you're messed up for quite a while and
among everything this movie hasn't it
there are a lot of trails leading to
places in this move everything so Webb
it's a tangled web we weave in civil war
movies also a black panther origin movie
this is where we see the beginning of
Black Panther or at least his
introduction to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but this dude is not messing
around this guy is out to kill Bucky
Barnes he's talking with Black Widow
black widows like we'll find the person
who murdered your father and he was like
don't worry I'll kill them myself
he's the king of Wakanda he's their
leader you imagine if Barack Obama was
like don't worry about it I will kill
him myself
I feel like Oh [ __ ] he's not messing
around Tron strike
oh that's not to say but at a point in
this movie the greatest superhero
Throwdown in a movie ever happened I am
I was so entertained in this Throwdown
that was at the airport was pretty much
lines divided and now everyone's gonna
fight I mean everyone's fighting
everyone everyone had a solid moment to
shine at least one moment in this movie
man I was dying laughing an ant man an
ant man's like I'm gonna try something I
was like what's he gonna try then he
turned big and he grabs Rody's or AHA I
was like oh [ __ ] that's right turd
he doesn't just turn small man Ant Man
could turn big sharks like all right as
anyone on our team have any really
miraculous tricks they now want to throw
idea now's the time
ant-man has a little truck his all right
cap throw this at this right go boom
this big trucks going after rody is like
oh you have got to be kidding me and it
blows up and mans like I thought
that was a water truck that was a
gasoline truck just about killed rody I
just so completely loved that throw down
because also it gave us a chance to see
spider-man in action how they're making
spider-man and dude I cannot stress
enough Tom Holland is the greatest
spider-man I've seen on screen yet now I
have I in their own way love any of the
renditions of spider-man that we have
gotten on the big screen the spider-man
iterations that I hold to my heart that
made me love spider-man was the 90s
cartoon the 90s animation in the Tobey
Maguire spider-man but Tom Hall and guys
and gals this guy reminded me why I
first fell in love with spider-man
because he was a teenager this stuff was
blowing his mind he talked like a
teenage kid like when Bucky punches at
him he grabs his head it's like you have
a metal arm that is awesome dude is like
a big fan you can tell that he was a
teenager fighting a long slide and
against all these heroes that he himself
has loved
he was fanboying out a bit and he should
be fanboying out because he is not an
Avenger he's not a big super he's not
like I'm him spider-man I'm the best
ever
he hasn't been at this long and so he
should act like a teenage kid fighting
alongside heroes and they did that very
well because spider-man what made him
great what continues to make him great
is he was the one that went against the
grain of superheroes you had Batman he
went super man you had all these heroes
that were men and children can aspire to
be like them they are men and you can be
them too as long as you eat your green
vegetables so you know the nerdy kid
would read that like oh I want to be
like that spider-man was the one that
came along was like hey no nerdy kid you
too can be a hero because that nerdy kid
is spider-man totally went against the
grain it was great back then it's great
now and it's celebrated in this movie
hope it continues to be celebrated as
Tom Holland continues to be spider-man I
believe it will be I will say that
Scarlet Witch she is Opie as tears how
many times and that throw a huge
superhero battle does she save someone's
ash like blocks someone's foot and
throws them or block someone else and
like I mean these kill shots she is
avoiding because she's moving people
with her mind but let's be honest man
her big moment was when she goes up
against vision and she's doing her like
abracadabra [ __ ] visions like she shuts
down the crystal in his head who's like
do rulers rooms she just like had tokens
him through about 38 floors of building
I was like okay yeah that's the badass I
always heard about yeah it was great age
of Ultron seen her rip Ultron drones in
half but this was just a bit more
impressive definitely kicked ass to his
movie she's one of my favorite
characters in this movie but then
tragedy strikes the team when Rhodey
alik vision is cradling maximov because
you know he wants to hit that then he
shoots his gem it Falcon and then Falcon
dodges it and smacks Rhodey in the chest
just dude free falls a more machine just
free Falls and splats on the ground he's
paralyzed now that sucks because I like
roadie and but I do like the fact that
ultimately I feel like they're gonna be
like alright roadies gonna be in a
wheelchair but the war machine suits
gonna make him walk so he's pretty much
gonna be like that mantis series say you
guys remember that no well I do so there
but the big holy [ __ ] moment in this
entire thing of everything that I've
explained and talked about was the scene
where Captain America and Bucky are in
fortress of evil looking for the other
winter soldiers that are ultimately
irrelevant and useless and there's their
and then Tony Stark comes as Iron Man
he's like hey don't worry I'm on your
side and then Daniel Bruhl scare achter
I'm gonna say this here in my first
review I was like eight ultimately I
feel like he was kind of useless and he
didn't really contribute much to the
plot I still feel like that overall but
I really did appreciate the tragedy of
his character a lot more the second time
I saw like I said a lot happens in this
movie sometimes you got to watch a movie
twice in order to really gather
everything sometimes three times
sometimes four times but when he kept
like listening on the phone and first
you're like oh his wife's calling him
and then you're like oh no she's dead
and that's just a message that he keeps
listening to you're like oh that's
success so I did appreciate him a lot
more the second time I saw the movie and
I really liked the actor so there that
is what it really comes to a head right
when he turns on this computer screen
and you see the street corner you're
like I think that's the wreck at the
beginning and then Tony Stark's like I
know this street what is this you're
like oh [ __ ] oh god no oh god ah mmm no
not this yet Bucky Barnes killed his
parents
Captain America knew about it kept it
from Tony Stark Tony's pissed he is
going after Bucky with a vengeance he
wants blood and I completely at this
point I was like
I get I get it but I also get Captain
America trying to save his friend it's
like this guy's Tony Stark has never
really reconciled with his dad he had
regrets about it I mean this is
established through all the movies he
was never close to his father but you
can tell after his death he wanted to
reconcile but never got that chance and
up till now he wrote it off as
happenchance he's like well they died
and [ __ ] happens but I move on you know
he repressed it he repressed his
emotions he says in this movie he's like
yeah I do president I didn't want to
deal with it he deflects it's very deep
down inside but you know [ __ ] happens
but now Bucky Barnes killed his parents
all that rage now comes to a head and
now he has someone to blame he's like no
you're the you're the one who did it
you're the reason I never got to
reconcile you are the reason for any
misery that I've carried for all these
years I'm going to kill him yeah you
have those issues and then you watch a
video someone's smashing your dad's face
in and choking your mom and you say go
ahead and try to save me like yeah I
would have let him live no you'd
probably try to kill the dude too
however on Captain America side he's
like he was a victim he didn't do it he
was made to murder your parents he
remembers and he carries that guilt with
him do not blame Bucky for what Hydra
did Hydra killed your parents that's
their fault then you look at Steve
Rogers and you think yourself all right
think of your best friend best lure
whoever whoever you're closest to then
imagine a super evil organization
captured him brainwashed him made him
murder people still carries the scars of
it he remembers all of it it's
traumatized him it's super tragic and
then imagine somebody trying to kill
your friend you would defend him again
Donatello and turtles - he's right he's
right they're both right at the end of
the very emotional throat and Bucky has
his metal arm blasted off and then Steve
Rogers takes his shield and just jams it
into Tony Stark's little arc reactor and
he has no more power for his suit he's
taking Bucky he has a shield and Starks
like that shield doesn't belong to you
you don't deserve it my father made that
shield and you're like oh gosh that's a
it's a really good point you even see
Captain America's like all right he just
drops the shield he's like I can't say
he's wrong about that the post-credits
scene was rather a - postcards at 1
mid-credits scene and then a
post-credits scene mid-credits scene was
Bucky goes back under
is because he's like I can't even do I
can't trust my own brain I mean
obviously there are sequence of words
that were used in this movie that made
me snap and you know folks got messed up
so he goes back under the eyes and you
know he's going to come back for
infinity war hopefully then the second
one was spider-man you defeat her
Parker's in his room he's got a black
eye and super hot aunt Mazal patching
his eye up and then she leaves and his
web slinger has a projection that comes
out of it looks up as the spider-man
symbol like you know the flashlight you
had when you were a kid yeah that's
shining on the ceiling this says
spider-man will return which I found
interesting because we need a spider-man
was going to be in his own movies by
Sony but it's like wait do you mean like
he's returning in his own set of movies
or do you mean he's going to return in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe those are
two completely different things I don't
want to know I mean I suppose now the
integration has happened between the
spider and with Sony's spider-man and
the Marvel Cinematic Universe I
implication you would think spider-man
would come back when there's a super
evil destructive demigod about to wreck
your world [ __ ] yeah I imagine
spider-man would come back now that he
is a part of that world one thing I
thought of though the Infinity stones if
he gets all of them vision is gonna die
he's gonna rip that thing out of his
head visions toast I just I didn't think
about that that sucks now which team am
I on I am on a team if I had to choose a
team at a gun to my head I can choose
one I got my team it's really funny at
the end of my spoiler-free review set a
punch in the camera I had the Iron Man
glove people like oh that's clearly what
T meson funny isn't it that moment you
realize you don't know [ __ ] hink at
Merrick
that's someone okay it's like that I was
looking for a full size you know adult
shield that I could be like uh like
really impressive like couldn't find one
for the price I wanted for one second in
a video and the thumbnail and couldn't
find one that was shipped in my house
fast enough because it was kind of an
afterthought and I just thought but
recently so I got this thing it's really
it's a magnet those pretty neat pretty
strong magnet yeah you saw it on the
thumbnail no no I just took a picture of
it like that and then I posed like that
superimpose them made it bigger boom its
thumbnail magic right there my friends
that's YouTube magic oh yeah teamcap all
the way the reason is because especially
at the end Tony Stark is coming from a
very emotional place but Captain America
is still logical he's like no we are not
the enemy
something else is the enemy so for Cap's
logic versus
Stark's emotional state I choose cap and
then in the initial arguments I saw both
sides of it but I'm more leaning towards
Kapoor he's like we are going to be a
tool at that point what if they want to
send us to a place we don't want to go
and fight for something what if like
Hydra they need to help Hydra somehow
the government says well that's just the
better of the alternatives it's like
let's [ __ ] Hydra but they could do
that like now you have to help Hydra
because we are working for another thing
so now the Avengers might help hide it's
just you know that scenarios out there
possible or what if there's another
scenario where it's like oh [ __ ] burning
that this guy is holding a building
hostage and if the building happens to
be a school is going to blow up all the
kids in the school but it's like the
super like oh no government can't
intervene because politics both of those
scenarios suck ass so I'm with cap is
like leave it as it is we have pretty
good discretion accidents happen but
good discretion generally guys in the
end this movie just hit so many great
notes and it's very rare to find a movie
that gets better the second time you
watch it I've imagined what it'll be
like the third time I watch it it's just
it's a rarity especially in the comic
book movie world alright guys so again I
ask you Captain America Civil War have
you seen it what did you think about it
or what's your favorite part of the
movie whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more Barclay I would
there's no epic
vision is cradling maksimov because you
know he wants to hit that about the
timer Scarlet Witch asked vision like
well what do you want and in vision says
something along the lines of for people
to see you the way I see you I was like
all right vis
don't know if you can read human
emotions that well because you're pretty
much Spock but I'm gonna let you know
right now you are in my friend you are
in just keep dealing you and you can do
each other because it's happening